تسممت إحدى منتقدات بوتين تقول
إنها تعرضت للتسمم لأنها
عارضت بوتين وحربه، تقول إلفيرا
فيكاريفا في أول مقابلة لها مع
وسائل الإعلام الغربية إنها تبلغ من العمر 33 عامًا وتتمتع
بصحة جيدة ولكن بعد ذلك حدث هذا فجأة، حيث
أصيبوا بتشنجات وخفقان في
بناء حدقة العين وآلام في المعدة.
اضطررت للذهاب إلى عيادة خاصة لعلاج
الأمر، وهو أمر غير
قابل للعلاج،
ولم يتمكن أحد من تقديم تشخيص ملموس، لقد أجرينا
العديد من اختبارات السموم المستخدمة في
حوادث التسمم، أخبرنا الخبراء
بإجراء تحليل للدم بشكل إجمالي، كان هناك
حوالي  4.5 ملليجرام من السم في نظامي
4.5 ملليجرام من السم في نظامها
عندما اختبرت ذلك ولكي أكون واضحًا هنا
سمعت صوتها بشكل صحيح والسبب في أننا
لم نتمكن من رؤية وجهها والسبب في
تحدثنا معها عبر الهاتف هو أنها
تقول  لقد أثر التسمم على
مظهرها أيضًا، والآن
تقول شركة "روسي أوتليت صودا" إن إلفيرا
تسممت بأملاح معدنية ثقيلة، وهي
تتحدث الآن عن أربعة
مليجرامات ونصف من السم، ويستشهدون بالفحوصات المخبرية
التي خضعت لها فيكاراجا بعد أن
بدأت تعاني من هذه الأعراض.
هذا هو الشيء المذهل الذي تظهره الجرافة في الخارج
وهو أنه لم يتم ردعها.
أنا لا أنوي مغادرة بلدي. كثير من
الناس حتى في هذه اللحظة يكتبون
ليطلبوا مني أن أحزم حقائبي على الفور
وأخرج من هنا حتى أنهم يعرضون
مساعدتي في ذلك.  هذا ولكنني
أخضع للمراقبة من قبل الأطباء وأنا أخضع
للعلاج،
ولا أنوي مغادرة البلاد
لأن لدي عدد كبير من
المؤيدين،
لا يصدق سماعها تقول ذلك
ويجب أن نقول إن ألفيرا الليلة هي
في الواقع واحدة من المحظوظين  تلك التي
لا تزال على قيد الحياة لتروي قصتها، لقد رأينا
قائمة طويلة بالطبع من
الوفيات الغامضة لروس بارزين منذ
بداية الحرب، ما لا يقل عن 14 شخصًا حسب
أحدث إحصاء لدينا، ونحن متحفظون للغاية
بشأن هذا الأمر الذي تنظر إليه  بعضها
على شاشتك سقط أحدهم بسبب الرياح في
الفندق الذي يقيم فيه، وسقط آخر من
نافذة المستشفى، وسقط آخر من على
الدرج، وسقط آخر من
القارب، لقد فهمت المقصد